I have big marijuana news not from the
United States but from the United
Kingdom the British government's uh
medicines and Healthcare Products
regulatory agency that's a mouthful as
found that cannabidiol also known as CBD
has a quote restoring correcting or
modifying effect on physiological
functions when administered to humans
this is a really big deal because for
the first time the British government is
saying we recognize officially the
medicinal potential of cannabis the UK
government has said there is medical
value here and this was a review done of
CBD which is the cannabinoid that
accounts for about 40% of what is
extracted from the marijuana plant it
does not contain THC THC is the
psychoactive component of marijuana
CBD does not contain THC but it's
purported to retain the health benefits
and this all stemmed from a conversation
about CBD vaporizer company Medi pen and
this is in stark contrast to the
petition that has been batted away by
the home office in the UK saying that uh
cannabis can unquestionably cause harm
to individuals and society so to break
it down for you here in the u.s.
marijuana
Schedule one drug meaning it is
considered the most dangerous most
addicting most potentially damaging of
all drugs in that category the home
office in the UK had something similar
which is they categorize marijuana as
unquestionably causing harm to
individuals in society now that we have
this declaration from this arm of the
British uh British government
administration we can open research
further and you can start to loosen some
of the very very oppressive restrictions
on marijuana research now uh I I still
am concerned that here in the United
States we have these five states that
are going to be voting on marijuana
legalization in November including here
in Massachusetts I'm worried that if we
ever completely legalize cannabis it's
going to be because we just
no longer afford to lock everybody up
not because it's actually the correct
ethical sensible thing to do uh and and
I know some will hear me say that and
they'll say well what matters is the end
not the means or the reason and just to
a certain it degree I agree with that
but really we need a total paradigm
shift here in the United States when it
comes to cannabis legalizing marijuana
and what's really really shocking to me
Pat is that when we review the studies
on the medical benefits of marijuana
it's not like they're difficult to find
there are so many studies where I mean I
just randomly looked and said let's just
see what medical studies there are
already in the US about marijuana but
there's one for example called cannabis
derived substances in cancer therapy and
emerging anti-inflammatory role for the
cannabinoids this is by Lee and others
from 2010 there's another one called
inhibition of glioma growth in vivo by
selective activation of the cb2
cannabinoid receptor by Sanchez and
others I'm not just gonna read titles of
studies to you now there are hundreds of
these and this is with research being
difficult to do which say there's real
potential for cancers and so many other
conditions here in the United States
maybe someone in the u.s. government
will will take direction from what's
going on in Britain right now because
the evidence is pretty clear-cut at this
point yeah and of course we both support
the recreational legality of marijuana
yeah but medical use approving it is the
important first step and if someone has
glaucoma or epilepsy or answer I mean
how can you go to someone and they're
experiencing very minimal side effects
no harm to anyone else how can you tell
them that they're not able to use that
drug yet well it's circular the
reasoning a circular you can't use that
because it's schedule one well why does
it make sense for it to be Schedule one
it's like when you go to a company and
there's some insane policy that doesn't
make any sense and you say well but that
doesn't make sense can't we do something
different about this and they say I wish
we could but that's just the policy well
the the policy is arbitrary that we've
created the policy and it's time for us
to take responsibility and fix the
policy it's absolutely insane and some
good news from the UK
about this moving in the right direction